The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
mitopencourseware@ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: The
next three classes
deal with a discussion of three
models, which we developed
in this class with Kevin
Lynch, and I've subsequently
changed and added to.
The three models are not unique.
They are examples
of models which
inform the form of the
city, have instructions
as who should take part,
have premises of materialism
or theism associated with them.
I'll go through the
first one today,
what we call the cosmic model.
And you can see that the
definitions of states
is subjective, control
science, nature, type, and form
tools will be what we will
discuss in this class.
The most common
theory associated
with the beginning of cities
has a materialist basis.
This is of course wrong.
The materialist basis
is based on the notion
that a surplus is produced
through agriculture.
And a surplus requires a system
of bureaucracy, a literature,
or literal elite, a method for
controlling irrigation systems,
and so on, and the
primitive notions of trade.
Why don't I just read you
a standard explanation
of surplus, because you
should remember the word.
It's an important
word in the theory
of city form, the notion
of the production of more
than you need.
It involves storage, it
involves the world of--
that's why I regard the
invention of the potter's wheel
is one of the more significant
inventions of humankind.
How do you store food?
What do you do with
the surplus of food
unless you have commodities
or containers that
can separate the food from the
corrosion forces of nature--
the surplus.
"Surplus production
beyond the immediate needs
of the community made possible
the emancipation of some people
from the toils of the land."
Here's an interesting
observation--
that if you produce excess,
you relieve certain people
of conventional duties.
We have excess
which relieves a man
to become the conductor of
the New York Philharmonic
Orchestra.
It's only when you
have a surplus which
is not taken into account in
much of our modern economics.
"But this creates
the opportunity
for specialized
source and groups
associated with namely scribes,
craftsmen, priests, warriors.
Surplus production
presumes irrigation
and efficient irrigation system
produces a complex bureaucracy.
And that means cities."
This theory, materialist
theory, is best written
about in Gideon Sjoberg's
book, The Preindustrial City--
S-J-O-B-E-R-G-- and in Gordon
Child, an Australian writer,
who wrote a book called
Man Makes Himself.
These are classic depictions
of surplus theory.
There's a version of
surplus subdivision,
of surplus theory
into two kinds.
One held by Jane
Jacobs in her book
The Economy of Cities,
which argues that
in the town of Catalhuyuk--
C-A-T-A-L-H-U-Y-U-K, was
the center for industrial
production of obsidian.
And agricultural served,
as it does conventionally
in our societies, as
the source of production
for industrial commodities
such as obsidian.
This is different from the
agricultural surplus, which
regards agriculture as
the primary function
and pays no attention
to material production.
Most students of
the origin of cities
now don't believe in either
of these two propositions.
So forget them.
They're not important.
The common version
of this new theory
suggests that original cities
were ceremonial centers, places
of holy ritual, which explains
the risky force of nature
and secured them
for human benefit.
Peasants supported
them voluntarily,
attracted by their
holy power, thus
arose a permanent priestly
class, awesome and seductive.
Only later did the marks of
urban civilization appear--
ore, trade, writing, extensive
cross-specialization, and so
on.
So that the first cities
were mental weapons, not
physical forces.
Now, let's look at some of
this a bit more carefully.
Joseph Rykwert in a book called
The Idea of a Town writing
about the definition
of Roman cities--
"the Romans are considered
to be the prime rationalists
of ancient times and
the towns are often
seen as rational outcomes
of surveying technique
and military fortification.
I quote, Rykwert says,
"the town is not really
a natural phenomenon,"
here setting up
a distinction between the
form of the town and nature.
We'll get into the
fallacies of biomorphosis
and so on as we go
through this class.
You will understand that
I'm not a naturalist.
I understand that everything
that happens around us
is processed by the
amount of material,
the 1,250 cubic centimeters
in the human brain.
It's interesting in talking
about the cosmic model
to notice the definition
in formal religion
of the idea of heaven.
Heaven is only a
concept of humankind.
We'll touch on that a bit later.
Lewis Mumford-- just choosing
little bits from these
sources--
"the original aspects
of temporary settlements
have to do with sacred
things, not just
with the physical environment.
They relate to a more valuable
and meaningful kind of life
where a consciousness that
entertains past and future
apprehensive primal mysteries
of sexual generation
and the ultimate
mystery of death
and what may lie beyond death.
These central concerns
about is the very reason
for the city's
existence, inseparable
from the economic substance
that makes it possible."
Another item from
Mumford talking
about the exaggerated
height and thickness
of walls in earlier cities.
The wall of Khorsabad
which is an Assyrian town,
the fourth capital city
of the Kingdom of Assyria,
built around 700 BC--
the walls are 75 feet thick.
There is no possibility that
you build 75 feet thick walls
for military purposes.
In Mumford's term, it
is only for the gods
that men exert themselves
so extravagantly.
It's a wonderful phrase.
Remember it, never forget it.
It's only for the
gods that men, if you
wish to enlarge
the notion of gods,
and I'll discussed the notion
of a god gene a bit later.
What we do is not only based on
simple postulates of function.
It's central to
architecture as a discipline
that it's only for
gods that men exerts
themselves so extensively.
Quoting from another source,
"every feature of the city
reveals the belief that man was
created for no other purpose
than to magnify
and serve his gods.
That was the city's
ultimate reason for being."
Now here you have
two postulates.
You have to survive,
you're at the birth
of an instrument, a city, which
both has to deal with-- so
your survival possibility.
You look to the stars.
The stars are permanent.
It's not really difficult
to erect a vertical stick,
a gnomon, in Mesopotamia.
And at noon, the stick will
cast a shadow to the north.
You'll be able to build
a compass around that.
At the same time
it's doing that,
you will wonder why the town of
Chang'an in 190 BC in China is
built according to the
stars of the Dipper.
I will show you a
slide of that plan.
It's one of the
remarkable plans.
So the stability of astronomy
in the earliest cycles of cities
and the creation of a deity
significance in relation
to each of these acts, it's one
thing to know where north is.
It's another thing to
build your city according
to the primary
objectives of religion.
We'll go on a little, but
picking up little aspect
to this.
Most of the
significant buildings
built in archaic times
involve enormous amounts
of human labor.
For the Pyramid of
Cheops, which has nothing
to do with function whatsoever.
It has nothing to
do with materialism.
It is in fact such an
exhaustion of materialism.
The Pyramid of Cheops took
100,000 men 20 years to build.
The Great Pyramid
of Cheops was built
with about 2,300,000 blocks
of stone, totaling about six
million tons in weight.
They have blocks that average
two and 1/2 tons, but range up
to 15 tons, which
have to be quarried,
handled, and
transported up a river,
lifted 100 feet to
the level of the site
with sledges, rollers,
sleepers, ropes, and levers.
You don't do that
for anything other
than the belief in
the post-secular life.
Egypt didn't produce
any large cities
for various reasons, which we'll
talk about later in this class.
But many argue that much of
the disposition of resources
consequently centered
on the building
of post-contemporary life.
The most significant buildings
in most of these early cities
are religious buildings.
They're generally built out
of compression structures.
Solomon's Temple at
1000 BC in Jerusalem,
Herod's Temple, 70 years
before the birth of Christ--
both enormous
compression structures.
Associated with these
compression structures,
which in generally can't
go up to more than 200
to 300 feet in height.
The temples of Chichen Itza in
Mesoamerica-- about 200 feet.
The Tower of Babel is
about 200 feet in height.
The Tower of Babel has
the Temple of Marduk
on the top of the
Tower of Babel.
All of this is
synchronous with the fact
that religion was interpreted
not by every person
but by gurus, by priests, people
who achieved enormous power,
but didn't distribute the
secrets of their power.
The Holy of Holies
in Solomon's Temple
is still being sought for
by filmmakers and people who
want to excavate under the
Holy Mountain in Jerusalem.
Of course, something which is
prohibited by political forces.
The origin of the mosque,
the church, and the synagogue
is later, in my view.
The democracy of religion, which
we all know utilized, I think
comes in a different pattern.
The first action that I
think in this direction
comes from the Jewish
exile in 700 BC.
Nebuchadnezzar and
the Babylonian Army
destroys the first
Solomon's Temple.
He takes the Jews
in exile to Babylon.
Babylon is the greatest city
in the world at the time.
The Jews don't abandon
their religion,
despite the fact that
they don't have a temple
and they don't have priests.
They start praying
in schools, in homes.
Ezekiel appears as part of--
how many chapters of
Ezekiel are in the beginning
of the Old Testament?
A whole bunch of them.
What are they about?
They are all about
measurements of a temple.
These measurements
have been interpreted
in all kinds of ways over time.
The fact is that when the Jews
were released from Babylon
in exile, they
returned to Jerusalem
and Israel read the Bible to
the people for the first time.
Later on, I think one of
the conflicts about Jesus,
in my view-- and I will go
into this in more detail
in the story of Jerusalem--
is the fact that the synagogue
and the democratic religion
was growing in power
under the Pharisees
and that Herod's Temple
was the last resort
of the power of the priests.
And Jesus was a
confrontation to the priests,
to the Jewish priests,
who are on the way out.
And his death was the mark of
the transition in Christianity
from, well, the birth of
Christianity to the church--
and later on, 700 years
later, to the mosque.
So we have an image of
the pre-democratic church
environment as buildings
of compression,
no penetration of the
building by the people,
the slaughtering of animals.
At Solomon's Temple, I
think 200,000 animals
were slaughtered, or 20,000.
It doesn't matter.
It's just a number.
The giving a gift at
the birth of a ritual
is also part of that
same phenomenon.
Many of these
priestly directions
still occur in some ways
in contemporary religion.
Anyway, so we have
an image of a town
as a pristine object
which changes very
regularly and under control.
It doesn't change sporadically,
it stays the same.
Population growth is very
low, death rates are high.
Population growth rates in
medieval Europe due to disease
was something like
0.6% per annum.
So the idea that things change
very radically and very rapidly
is a very contemporary idea.
You could build a city in
which everything roughly was
the same.
And the routines for
understanding it and managing
it are also more
or less the same.
This kind of city is a
mental force in itself.
It accumulates the
understanding of it,
it's perpetuated
through rituals.
Rituals, according to
Mircea Eliade, E-L-I-A-D-E,
a Romanian religious philosopher
whom I will quote for in a few
minutes, these
are distinct-- oh,
let's wait until we get there.
Human life is thereby given
a secure and permanent place.
The gods [INAUDIBLE]
is kept often,
not incidentally, the
structure of human power,
of priests and kings, and
abilities is also maintained.
Let's listen to Eliade's
depiction of archaic man.
"If we observe the general
behavior of archaic man,
we are struck by
the following fact--
neither the objects
of the external world
nor human act,
properly speaking,
have any autonomous
intrinsic value.
Objects or acts acquire
the significance
and become real
because they reenact
after one fashion or another a
reality that transcends them."
This is difficult
stuff to understand.
"Amongst my countless stones,
one stone becomes sacred,
and then instantly becomes
saturated with being.
It becomes reality as opposed
to an everyday reality.
It constitutes a hierophany
H-I-E-R-O-P-H-N-E-Y,
because it commemorates a
mythical act, and so on.
The object appears as the
receptacle of an external force
to differentiate it from
the crude product of nature.
The object fashioned
by the industry of man
acquire the reality,
the identity,
only to the extent of
their participation
in a transcendent reality."
In relation to the
form of cities,
Eliade talks about three things.
Reality is a function
of the imitation
of a celestial archetype.
I mentioned before.
Number 2, the symbolism
of the center.
Why a center?
The word Babylon means the
conjunction of the heaven
and earth and the subterranean.
Jerusalem is known for its
being a city on the ground.
In Christianic terms, there's
a city 15 miles above.
Raphael paints a wonderful
picture of the earthly city,
heavenly city.
Pope Urban II in 1080 in talking
to the Crusades in Europe
before they set off
for Jerusalem talks
to them about taking the earthly
city and the heavenly city.
The invention of heaven
is a human invention.
The Hebrews, the Jews didn't in
early accept the idea of a life
beyond the normal daily
experience of life.
The center is not
only the position
of maximum concentration,
it is the position
of maximum identification.
It's described in many of
these terms in cosmic terms
not only as a functional
economic center, but as
the central place which
distinguishes itself
from other place.
In Eliade's terms, there's a
difference between the sacred
and the profane.
The profane is the
everyday world.
Reverse it, our secular world
is not in our terms profane.
But in archaic times, he argues,
the secular world is profane.
The religious world,
the only world,
purposely created through
hierophany of significance.
Eliade argues that the third
impact on the form of towns
were rituals,
significant gestures
to acquire meaning
attributed to them.
I might not have time to go into
these examples in China, India,
and Mesoamerica.
But in the town of
Madurai in Southern India,
I will show you a slide of the
ritual still practiced today
of each cycle of
time as time passes.
According to Eliade, progress
does not seen in terms of time
by archaic man.
Time was not linear--
time was circular.
There's no notion
about the past.
The present, the existence
of important things
is very much in association
with the security
that you give to everything.
I'm just conscious
of time so I'm
going to go through,
skip some of this stuff
and try to concentrate
on a few of the items.
What I'd like to
do is in relation--
oh, I didn't tell you
what I handed out to you.
I'm sorry.
This is an image of a town.
Where is it?
It's a rather famous city.
It's a classical city.
It's Athens.
The image shows Athens
is being built largely
around an elevated
system of space
called the Acropolis,
a religious god.
And its extension to the water
around the town of Pireas,
the Harbor of Pireas,
depicts the implication
of building a town whose form
is much more mechanical and much
more of the kind that we
will talk about next Tuesday.
We have two forms of the
same system, one dedicated.
We know Pireas is purely a place
in conjunction with an expanded
view of the Mediterranean--
the Acropolis of Athens
plus the monuments of gods
all over Athens.
Depicts a consciousness
of what we
might call the religious gene.
The greatest gene is a
term taken from archaeology
relatively recently.
And based on excavations
in the Mayan world, which
argues that belonging
to religions
was a very, very early
phenomenon, largely
because of the security
the community gave--
belonging to the same thing
provided fundamental security.
And the god gene, in a Darwinian
sense, is built into all of us.
Those of us who
don't believe in god
are not part of
the Darwinian bet--
we are creatures of obstinance--
and since the
Enlightenment have been
free to criticize
whatever we want to based
on fact or on mythology.
I'm going to go
through the components
of a theory on the second page.
AUDIENCE: I have question.
JULIAN BEINART: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Regarding the
layout of having both Athens
and Pireas at the same time.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] social
division between them?
And if so, what were
the different types
of social groups, like
division one versus the other?
JULIAN BEINART: Athens during
the fifth century, and only
for one century,
experimented with democracy.
At that time, all citizens
were considered equal,
except for women or slaves.
There's a machine in
the museum in Athens
which is almost like
a machine in which you
put in your fingerprint and
it registers you for voting.
So in Democratic Athens,
as Socrates would explain,
all people were considered
equal in the first notion
of a crude democracy.
It didn't last very long.
Athens is situated in rocky
country, very poor agriculture.
So it's dependent on other
sources of basic supply
of food, such as wheat.
In later years, it
was so desperate
that it tried to attacked
Sicily, which has always been
a center of wheat production.
So Pireas was part of the
extension of Athens for food.
It was purely a
machine-like enterprise.
It only had to produce
goods for the service
of the democratic capital,
which was experimenting
with all kinds of ways
of life, including
the purposeful
application of democracy.
Within Athens, democratic
Athens itself, yes, there
were areas where
the more powerful
lived and there were areas
with the less powerful.
Socrates himself used
to walk through Athens
on a daily basis.
It was small enough to do that.
And he would go through
different neighborhoods,
according to his
own descriptions.
Socrates never wrote, of course.
So it's all told by
Plato and other people.
But that's the short
answer to a long question.
The history of Athens is an
interesting story in itself.
And I hope we'll have
some chance in this class
to deal with it.
I'm not sure that I am
going to, but we'll try.
The other sheet is a plan of
Angkor Wat, 13th, 14th century
city in Cambodia,
which I want to use
as an illustration of the
conjunction between built
form associated with
religion, built form also
at the same time serving
practical purposes.
The feng shui in China
faces houses to the south.
You are the lady who knows
more about China than I do.
Feng shui is a mystical
system for the selection
of the site for the
location of buildings
which, practically speaking,
faces in the right direction.
Feng shui would be
hopeless if it faced houses
towards the north in a climate
in the northern hemisphere.
The same with my description
of the Hindu structure
of Angkor Wat.
Let's look at some of these
components of a theory.
First of all, the
notion of returning.
If there is
discrimination in places
which have been struck by
hierophany and therefore
more significant, they would
be relatively few of them.
And some would be given
particular mythological
significance, and the idea of
retaining would be significant.
Mumford says, in the
history of cities
the magnet comes
before the container.
It's an interesting
sentence to remember.
Movement towards cities,
called urbanization
in contemporary times,
is a reenactment
of a ritual of movement
to special places--
in our case is now to
secular capital cities
or industrial cities
or economic cities.
I will show you a
slide of Olympia
in Greece, the birth
of the Olympic games,
held every four years from
776 BC, a place to which
we return in only four years.
The contemporary
Olympic games has also
maintained the cycle
of returning to a place
every four years.
Hitler wanted the
Olympic games after '36
to be in Berlin forever.
In fact, he and Speer
designed a stadium
which was so large that the
Olympic rules would have to be
changed to fit the stadium.
But that was
Hitler's prominence.
Hitler also invented the idea
of carrying the Olympic flame,
which now becomes an
economic popular piece
of the Olympic games.
776 Olympic site was
a religious site,
which priests walked around.
Hitler, in trying to
manifest the assumption
of the meritocracy
of the Aryan race,
made special attempts to
link Germany under Hitler
with Greece, with
the Athenian culture.
A lot of archaeology
was sponsored
by German researchers.
Hitler wished to combine the
permanence and the predominance
of the Aryan race.
So he took the idea of
taking the flame from 776,
the site of 776
BC, and taking it
to that point of the earth
where the games would
be held there four years.
There's no other significance
to the carrying of the flame.
There was no flame carried in
the original Olympic games.
It's only a creation of
a manic manifestation
of racial supremacy.
But there are places in the
world which still venerate
the idea of pilgrimage,
which is still
a fundamental source
in Islam for returning
to Mecca each year, places
like Varanasi and Fatima
in Portugal, places that
have been sanctified
in some way or other.
Pilgrimage-- I'll deal with
pilgrimage in another class.
Pilgrimage is a very
interesting function
of lateral movement
between cities
prior to the economic
significance of economic trade.
Natural phenomena, number 2.
Angkor Wat had a population
of, some people argue,
as large as a million
people in the 14th century.
I don't believe it, but
there is no way of knowing.
It's significance in size
was based on the fact
that it had enough water to
produce more than one crop
of rice per year.
Sometimes with that
amount of water,
you could produce three
crops of rice per year,
therefore feed an
enormous population.
The plan of Angkor has
two large water systems--
two are called baray, B-A-R-A-Y.
The west baray is about 7
kilometers in length.
The east baray, about 5.
These are large bodies of water.
They are precisely enclosed.
The deviation of the
rectangular geometry
is something like 0.01% error.
They are perfectly
constructed water bodies.
Between the water are towers.
In religious terms,
in Hindu terms,
the towers stand for
the peaks of Mount Meru,
between which are seven
oceans and six continents,
with Meru in the center.
The lakes are the
depictions of oceans.
When I visited Angkor
for the first time,
my guide said to me
that there was no water
outlet from these two
baray water systems
to an external water source.
There's a large 87
kilometer lake a number
of kilometers away from Angkor,
but these are religious items,
these water bodies, but they
have no practical significance.
Recent archaeology
has established
that there's a big water supply
system from Angkor to Lake
Tonle Sap, I think it is.
So here you have
the ambivalence--
the city in creating an
ambivalence of symbolism.
It works symbolically and
also works practically.
Whoever you are, you can
associate the significance
with symbolism.
It's a kind of curious
democracy that you
can choose which system
you want to believe
for the genuine
authority for your town.
We give everybody the chance,
if they have any kind of--
forget about
contemporary analogies.
I don't want to make
Another aspect of
significance in [INAUDIBLE]
we talk about archaic
times is that one
of the reasons we don't know
about the origin of language
because there is nothing about
language that is fossilized.
Much of our knowledge of
what I'm talking about
is based on fossilization.
And stone fossilizes
much longer than wood.
The empty space where the king
of Angkor Wat or the emperor
of Angkor Wat sat
is now a blank space
because wood is deteriorated
faster than stone.
Measuring the stars--
all the Babylonian cities
had the archive in the
[INAUDIBLE] system.
The City of [INAUDIBLE] was
marked after the Cancer.
The city of Nineveh was
marked after Ursa Major.
The City of Assur--
after Arcturus.
I've already
mentioned the creation
of the City of
Celestials, Jerusalem,
was created by God
before the city was
built by the hand of man.
St. Augustine found three
versions of Jerusalem,
sometimes referring to
the earthly Jerusalem,
sometimes to the heavenly,
sometimes to both at once.
St. John-- forget
about St. John.
He had an extraordinary--
his size of Jerusalem
was about 1,500 miles
long, about half
the area of the
United States, so much
for believing the disciples.
There's a book
called The History
of Heaven, which is an
interesting bit of little book.
He discusses how contrived the
notion of heaven actually is
and how as far as the
money is his religion
became stronger as Christianity
took over from Judaism
and Islam took over
from Christianity, Islam
occurs a millennium, 700
years after Christianity.
The Koran has much
more attention
paid to it to
ecclesiastical circumstances
to post-living circumstances.
You could almost understand in
the Koran is when I read it,
how joyous it would be
to be in the afterlife
then in secular life.
This notion of
privileging the afterlife
is of course criticized
by Marx as one
of these many
critiques of religion,
that it is nothing natural
about making humankind suffer
through the abuses
of mankind in return
for which you have promised
ecclesiastical benefit.
Just want to rush through
these so we have time.
Fixing places.
In the feng shui system,
there are ways in which
you can find a site for a town.
The tradition of
divining, dousing,
geomancy, astrobiology,
were all primitive methods,
if you want to call them
pseudosciences for determining
a place.
A place is not to be taken
by a developer as a site
for an old age community.
A place is one which has sacred
significance in this model.
The center of the
Earth, the Axis Mundi,
is the center of
all the centers.
It is an accommodation
of the cosmic model.
In the Jewish religion, the
Temple Mount in Jerusalem
is the site of Adam, and each of
the site of Abraham and Isaac's
offering to God and
God's willingness
to stop Abraham
sacrificing Isaac.
All of this is sedimented
into the Jewish religion.
The Temple Mount--
both Solomon's Temple
and Herod's Temple are
built on the Temple Mount,
making this the center not only
of Judaism but of the world.
And Judaism was arrogant enough
that until the birth of Christ
it was the center of the world.
Christianity, for
reasons which I'll
go into in the
history of Jerusalem,
in the case study of
Jerusalem, didn't abide by.
For 500 years, the Temple Mount
was a dump of Roman ruins.
The Church of the
Holy Sepulcher was
built to turn away
from the Temple Mount.
When the first members of
Islam came into Jerusalem,
and they wanted
to choose the site
for their own religious place.
They chose the Temple Mount,
not the Christian sites.
The Christians finally turned--
it's too much of a detail.
I'd have to draw it to
make it more sensible.
AUDIENCE: Why did they
choose a Jewish site versus--
JULIAN BEINART: Because they--
AUDIENCE: A Christian site?
JULIAN BEINART:
Because they claim
to have many of the same
religious heritage, Abraham,
many of the religious gods.
Jerusalem was always considered
the second or third largest,
most significant in
the Fatiha literature,
which celebrates cities.
Jerusalem, after
all, the mythology
of the ascent from the
Dome of the Rock to heaven
is important mythology in Islam.
The Dome of the Rock is one of
the most significant buildings
in Islam.
It's on the Temple Mount.
Al-Aqsa Mosque is
on the Temple Mount.
There's a continuity
of even violently
different religious forms,
excepting Axis Mundi.
There's an economy
of religious sites.
If you're not sure
about your god,
maybe the fact that the
previous god sanctified a place.
It's like buying
into a firm that's
had a good economic record,
even if you are in competition
with the firm itself.
AUDIENCE: Were they expecting
a grid system by doing that?
JULIAN BEINART: I don't know.
We'd have to get in when we do
the case study in Jerusalem.
And I can talk about
it in more detail.
We can talk about--
there's only one
place in Jerusalem
where all three religions
are represented vertically.
It's the Christian,
Islam, Jewish--
the Tomb of David, the Christian
Last Supper, and the Islam
Ottoman Manifestation above it.
I'll go into that with
diagrams and show.
How are we doing?
OK, we've got a
few more minutes.
Another aspect of
this kind of city
is the definition of boundaries.
Boundaries and ritual
perambulation--
the celebration of the
Kingdom of Phnom Penh
involved people circulating
around the town.
Joshua and Jericho, a
circuit of the white walls
of Memphis for each new
coronation of a pharaoh.
A Jewish synagogue
where you perambulate
around the central--
not the Torah, but
the central locus
from where the prayer is
read is a perambulation.
Romulus in the circular
rampart traced by the plow
to ensure the safety of Rome.
The Roman Mundus, the meeting
of the Earth and the lower
regions.
The Laws of the
Indies, which built
much of Central America and
St. Augustine in Florida
all the way to Los Angeles,
says that the settlement
should have a stockade,
even though there
is no fear of military
action from residents.
The idea of mocking away
your world begins and ends
is significant.
We have a problem
about cities now
which dribbled into
some other form, then
what architects consider to
be the central site of a city.
The bimodal or the bi--
I don't know if it's exactly
bimodal, it's not bimodal.
It's the concept of having
more than one allegiance, which
is baffling.
Cities are always, as
I quoted Marx, class,
cities presume any difference
between the country
and the city, that as
long as that mark was
clear and understood through
walls, everybody was happy.
Once the city expanded
beyond the walls,
we have been left in doubt.
This model made no
place for doubt.
[INAUDIBLE] the center is
circumvented by a form.
There's another pretty
curious example of this kind.
In Dorset, in England,
there are stone mounds
which, seen from the
air, form giant forms.
In southern Peru,
the Nazca lines
are huge conglomerates
of huge spiders,
identical, these lines
up to 900 feet long.
In Glastonbury, in
England, there's
a planispheric circle
10 miles in diameter.
There's a Gemini figure
made up of field forms.
These unexplained
natural devices,
which must have in
some ways had to do
with a system of
cosmic identity.
The geometry of the land.
The Romans, despite
their great rationality,
used the system
of augury to find
the right place
in the countryside
from which to
survey could begin.
They ended up with the Decumanus
Maximus being the east-west,
and the Cardo Maximus being
the north-south axis of a town.
This directional cardinality
occurs in a number of places.
The Kaaba is depicted with four
quarters and diagonal lines
running to the
corners northeast.
The Union Jack is a
flag of the same plan.
Not only does it symbolize
the center of the Axis Mundi,
but it depicts things, that
you get the quartier in France
as a part of the city.
You get the notion
of the headquarters--
what is the headquarters?
It's a Axis Mundi
in military terms.
I'm tempted to, in this
case, just do a drawing.
This is an early symbolic
map of Mexico City.
The Aztec leader's
name is Tenoch.
He's depicted as next to an
eagle landing on the water
with four streams, of course,
suggesting a connection
outwards to the
rest of the world.
I choose this as an example
of this kind of figure.
I choose it for another
interesting silly reason.
What is the name of the
first city in the Bible,
the Christian-Jewish Bible?
AUDIENCE: Enoch?
JULIAN BEINART:
Why do you know it?
AUDIENCE: It's Cain's son.
JULIAN BEINART: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And then it's that
name minus the [INAUDIBLE]..
JULIAN BEINART: Why
do you think there's
a conjunction in the name?
AUDIENCE: I have no idea.
JULIAN BEINART: I haven't
the faintest idea either.
The first city in the Bible
is curiously called Enoch.
What is Enoch?
It's the name of Cain's son.
Adam's Hut in Paradise,
Joseph Rykwert's book,
presumes that paradise
was perfection.
There was no need for shelter.
There's no need for
architecture in paradise.
We have changed that
view, of course.
Architecture is
important for everything.
Cain is banished from paradise.
He's a murderer-- he
murders his brother.
He forms the first
city, the first cities
of crooks, murderers.
The first urban
community in the Bible
is a community of retrogrades,
of people who have
been expelled from paradise.
The Christian view
of this is that there
must be something
extraordinary about the city
and goes into the question of
salvation, and so on and so on,
which I don't understand.
But Enoch is the
name of the town.
The whole idea--
Kevin Lynch was always
fascinated by the idea
of why people name towns
after their children.
And he had a kind of convoluted
theory, which I can't
remember as to why that occurs.
But here, Enoch
is the first city
in the Judeo-Christian
enterprise, a city of evil,
although it's been
sanctified in other ways.
But this is
Tenochtitlan, having a
assuming a similar
kind of reach out,
an Axis Mundi, where the most
important thing takes place,
the eagle is a symbol of
some kind, in any case,
the leader is next to the eagle.
It lands on the water.
The site is a lake.
The cactus, for some
reason or other,
is the permanent
prodigious natural form.
Do you know anything
about cactus?
I never know to explain
the cactus, anyway.
The second last of these items
is the consciousness of place.
I haven't got time to
go into this phenomenon
except to tell the
story of Levi-Strauss'
telling in Tristes Tropiques.
Levi-Strauss studies the Bororo.
The Bororo are a
primitive group of people
in the Mato Grosso in Brazil.
Much like the Dogon
in Africa, they
are a kind of naive people.
The Dogon do wonderful sculpture
and put their sculpture
often in places for posterity.
Bororo is a system in which
the town or the village
is circular.
Each place has a
particular identity.
And what are called moieties.
There's a belief systems
are related to the place
that you occupy.
When the Salesian missionaries
came to missionize the Bororo,
they replaced the
circular locations
with rectangular constructions.
The Bororo lost not only
their sense of place,
but their sense of identity.
So responding to the existence,
the psychic existence,
was their position in place.
We have elements of it today
in our religious life--
those of you who
have religious lives.
The position of place in
front of the altar in relation
in front of the cross,
the carrying of the cross,
and so on.
There's a story in South African
history of the famous battle
between the Zulus and
the Afrikaners in Natal
in which the versions of
history are very different.
The Zulus claim that
the white settlers
tried to get into the
women's quarters, which
are highly separate identities
in a circular system.
The Afrikaners claim that the
white people were attracted
to the center of this
town and were then killed,
leading to the famous
Battle of Blood River,
and so on and so on.
Numerology, which
I won't go into,
if you read the cosmology
of Chinese cities,
we should have enough.
The nine square system,
figures adding up vertically
and horizontally
to the number 15.
I'm throwing at you a lot of
little stories, fragments.
There's no coherent overall text
on what I tried to describe.
As for what it means
today, it's up to you to--
or up to us to
make sense of this.
We still have people
standing before judges.
We still have a
significant night.
Why build a Tower of
Babel 300 feet high?
Why built the
Temple of the Moon.
It's the Temple of the Moon.
In Tenochtitlan on the Street
of the Dead, to the same height
and put the priests on the top.
There are many fragments of this
which make up an idea of a kind
of city which is no longer
prevalent in our thing
but still remains to the extent
when I said in our last class
that we cannot under Darwinian
science explain phenomenon such
as consciousness or mind.
Quoting from a
recent book called
Cosmos of Mind, which is a
critique of Darwinian science,
"architects more than
planners, by and large,
have a sense of the innate
importance of experience
and believe through working at
it and every day observation
and studying things you can
approximate good solutions."
Whether a street in
Fifth Avenue in Manhattan
has cosmic significance,
I don't know.
Whether the Macy's parade
adds to that significance
I don't know.
I certainly know that
the parade in Madurai
is different from
the Macy's parade.
This Macy's parade is
not a godly phenomenon--
it's the experience phenomenon.
As we go on in this case,
I'll be fussing around
with this
epistemological problem.
How much is assumed
in our construction
of the form of cities
in the rational system,
which we've learned
since the Enlightenment?
To what extent do we
consciously or how much
do we attempt to
maintain an interest
and extend in our explicit
interest in symbolic form?
Symbolic form is
a powerful measure
of the success of this
generation of cities.
There's no question that
all the evidence suggests
that our cities start with a
consciousness and expression
of religious form.
There is the stories.
You have to believe me--
no reason to.
Let's look at some pictures.
This is Kevin Lynch's
depiction of the sites
of cities that
we're talking about,
Mesoamerica around
about 1100 BC,
700 BC, Egypt, well, 3500 BC,
Jericho, 8000, Sumer, 4000,
Indus, 2500, Shang
China about 1700 BC.
Next.
OK, this is a painting of
the town of Catalhuyuk,
which Jane Jacobs
claims to have been
a center for the
production of obsidian
and used the agricultural
area around it as servicing
the industrial function.
The curious thing about
another depiction,
which is on the other slide,
is that there is hardly
any public space at all.
These are obviously alleys from
one group of houses to another.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: What's the
name of the [INAUDIBLE]??
JULIAN BEINART: Catalhuyuk--
C-A-T-A-L-H-U-Y-U-K.
It's in Anatolia.
I don't know whether
it's in Iraq or Turkey.
AUDIENCE: It's in Turkey.
JULIAN BEINART: It's in Turkey.
Catalhuyuk is Turkish, isn't it.
AUDIENCE: There is a book by
Bill Bryson called At Home
where he talks
about the ceilings
and how peculiar
are the entrances
and exits between buildings.
How is that
reflected in the map?
I'm trying to--
JULIAN BEINART: I don't know.
These maps, like the map
in just outside Oman,
the first map of Jerusalem,
are very abstract depictions.
This is a wall painting.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: And the
other one is an abstraction.
I would place very little
faith in the observations
of these towns.
Archaeology is
safer, and I don't
know how much archaeological
investigation has
been done at Catalhuyuk.
AUDIENCE: That's why
he talks about double
spaced in between and
a [INAUDIBLE] grid.
JULIAN BEINART: I don't
think it's Jane Jacobs,
but somebody has
spoken about the roofs
as being planes of utility.
I don't think there's
much to be gained.
It looks like a
contemporary drawing
for a squatter settlement.
Next.
Returning to particular place.
Banaras is on the left,
Kaaba on the right--
an annual pilgrimage,
an every day pilgrimage.
Next.
Catalhuyuk-- the
notion that the water
is the replication of the
ocean and the vertical building
the depiction of a mountain.
Mircea Eliade often talks
about mountains and cities
as being center in this
kind of cosmic model.
Next.
One of the reasons
for the towers
is because people
have no capacity
to span any large distance, so
the distances are very small.
Here is a parade of stone
figures on a sports field,
where it's just behind this.
The royal palace
doesn't exist anymore
because it's built out of wood.
Next.
The phenomenon, and
this is Chichen Itza.
Next.
Chichen Itza, Masada, one
of Herod's vacation homes
built on the side of the hill.
Again, the notion of
building on top of something.
The Romans finally
conquered Masada
by building a earth
bridge to the top.
Next.
A depiction of
the Babylon tower.
Not a very good one.
And the mixture of
astronomy and religion
in the case of Tenochtitlan.
Equinox sunrise over
the Templo Mayor.
Next.
Here's the city of the Dipper.
The constellations Ursa Major
and Ursa Minor superimposed
in the plan of Han
Dynasty, Chang'an.
The popular belief of subsequent
generations that the city was
consciously designed
to this pattern
is unsupported by any
independent event,
nor do the positions
of the imperial palaces
coincide with that of the
pulse star, and so and so.
There's some doubt about
this, but it's a nice drawing.
Next.
The astronomical
observatory in Chichen Itza.
A temple town in Southern India.
Now in each of these
vertical constructions
is not an astronomical
tower, but there's
a regularity of the vertical
phenomenon throughout the town
depicting something or other.
Next.
a gnomon, a tool
used by the Romans
for finding a propitious site.
And the geomancer's an
astrobiological instrument
for choosing the right site.
Next.
Chinchiri in Anatolia.
Interesting, the first town--
settlement is fortified
with a wall that
is small that surrounds the
town as intimately as possible.
When the town is
economically successful,
it builds itself in the
first century before Christ
a surrounding wall
which is based
on a superior geometry, a
perfect geometry, a geometry
which can be associated
with centrality,
with permanent symbolic
enclosure of high order
and so on.
Here the town of [INAUDIBLE]
in the 1st century BC.
It used to be in the
south of the USSR--
I don't know where it is now--
which has an
astronomical center.
It has astronomical
observation site in the center.
And the town follows the
pattern as it moves outwards.
Next.
The town of Edfu on the Nile.
Peculiar.
A marvelous conjunction
of light and shadow
in the marking of
a special place.
Edfu is the town.
It's a small town on
the banks of the--
AUDIENCE: Of the Nile.
JULIAN BEINART: But
you have replications
of this in Luxor and
in Karnak and so on.
I chose that one because I
happen to photograph it myself
and I was still struck
by the conjunction
of the positive light in
the form of the towers.
Here's a typical
perfect Chinese town.
The emperor is in
position number 1.
The subsequent position's
in 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
But the town is symmetrically
divided between right and left.
There's a color for the right,
there's a color for the left.
This is a town which is
perfectly controlled.
And its form is
a pristine object
for depicting symbolic
security and actual security.
Next.
Jerusalem is the head
of the three continents.
The Temple Mount, which I will
describe in much greater detail
as we go on in this class.
Next.
Oh, here we've gone out again.
Those are the formation seen
from the sky in Glastonbury
and Dorset.
Next.
The map of Mexico City and
the actual first settlement.
Next.
The moiety town of the
Bororo, the position
of the clan system, and
moiety A and moiety B,
specifying the
significance of place.
Place is not arbitrary.
Place is connected to
fundamental existence.
And here in the
town in Cameroon we
have a similar disposition of
man, wife, man, man, man, man,
man, man, wife, wife,
wife, and so on.
Not to be mixed up.
No cohabitation.
Next.
The depiction of place.
This is the Gate
of Heavenly Peace,
the marker of the distinction
between the whole Heavenly
City and the Sacred City, marked
here by a more recent emperor.
And here are the
location of the Mausoleum
to Mao on Tiananmen Square,
bereft of any disposition
of location which
is fundamentally wed
into the system of the town.
It is anywhere.
It looks as if it could be
anywhere, and it doesn't.
The strength of that
pattern on the left
is infinitely larger
than the strength--
the construction of
the right is not wed,
is not bred into the large
identity of the city.
Next.
It could be anywhere.
Let's just pass this.
This is a feng shui problem.
Next.
Depictions of the
system of approach
to the central imperial
position in the city.
Here are the idea
of a set of boxes,
revealing more as you
go into the system.
Next.
The mandala, the central
premise of the Indian system.
A depiction of the body
of the Brahma in a system
of subdivision of land here.
The Hindu religion
has a number of texts
about this siting of place.
The south Shilpa Shastras.
Here you see some
depictions of the way
in which the basic mandala
system can be demarcated.
Next.
Let's take one of them.
The village [INAUDIBLE] is
appropriate for retired life.
The village is one, two--
five parallel streets
from east to west.
Can you imagine us
living in a system where
we control the
environment so religiously
that a developer
in Florida would
be told to build a religious
center on this basis
of a mandala construction.
It's beyond our belief system.
Next.
Jaipur.
In Madurai the rituals
performed regularly
throughout the year conforming
to the town's structure.
So that when you are performing
a ritual, it is territorial--
you're passing
through territory.
Number 2, it is reinforcing your
notion of the plan of the town.
What do we do today to
reinforce your understanding
of the plan of Boston?
It's unnecessary.
Maybe if you're driving a car
and you move along the river,
there's some sensibility about
the movement from the suburb
to the center of the city.
Next.
The Street of the Dead.
Here's the vacant geometry
of a typical settlement
in the Mayan world.
Apparent lack of
axial relationships,
the so-called vacant
city because there's
very little evidence
the way people lived.
Again, what is left are
elements of stone construction,
monument.
I think that's the lot.
On Tuesday, we will
look at some examples
of a completely
different formal system,
one which is
open-ended, loose, not
regulated by a central force.
So, have a good weekend.